на форум Сполучені Штати нам не
підписали жодного розпорядження хоча ми
просили поїхати за власний рах мали всі
запрошення Разом з тим декілька десяткив
депутатів від слуг народа поїхали в
вашинктон за рахунок коштів платників
податків поки будуть існувати подібні
подвійні стандарти Ми створюємо
авторитаризм депутатів двох сортів і ми
як європейська Солідарність цим будемо
жорстко боротись на форум Сполучені
Штати нам не
підписали жодного розпорядження хоча ми
просили поїхати за власний рах мали всі
запрошення Разом з тим декілька десятків
депутатів від слуг народа поїхали в
Вашингтон за рахунок коштів платників
податків поки будуть існувати подібні
подвійні стандарти Ми створюємо
авторитаризм депутатів двох сортів і ми
як європейська Солідарність цим будемо